so let's bring in congressman brian
babin in texas and of course texas has
gotten the worst of it but not all of it
when it comes to how texas has been
affected congressman would the numbers
go up in texas at any point does
everyone anyone ever bring up that the
illegals are coming in here not exactly
vaccinated
not even tested
absolutely
great to be with you three
and
i can tell you that texas has taken the
brunt of this
and it's all because of the invitation
basically that the biden administration
has made starting back when he was a
candidate for president uh he has
reversed these wonderful policies that
worked uh and that were developed by
president trump back during his trial at
the border and that was back in 2019
and uh incredibly we saw secretary of
dhs mayarkas
this week
testified in front of the
homeland security committee and said
that the border under biden is no less
secure than under president trump and
that is the biggest whopper i've heard
probably in 25 years because as he said
that
that's when there were 15 000 illegal
immigrants that were underneath that
bridge and the numbers you're right
you're right they don't add up what's
happening the last i heard that there
were less than 2 000
uh haitians that were returned and
repatriated uh and there's uh there's
still up thousands and thousands of
illegals that are unaccounted for and
it's a shell game exactly what they did
uh early in the year when i went down to
the donna facility and saw
kids in cages kids in these in these uh
cells uh and uh then just a few days
later they took pictures of these kids
that uh that were were there now all of
a sudden these cells are empty all they
did was move them across the street so
that's the military what's happening to
military bases
and congressman you know the reason the
administration is stonewalling and when
you were referring to secretary marcus
he wouldn't even give a ballpark number
of how many people have been deported
it's because joe biden has got a problem
the republicans want our southern border
stronger and the democrats don't want
anybody deported so if they give a
number then it's like out look what joe
biden's doing he can't win either way
and ultimately what's going on
we can't win either way
well steve we know what the grand
strategy of the democrat party is they
want to change america a hope and change
it started under obama and now it's
really going at just racehorse speed
and
they want to change america and they
want to
they want to replace the american
electorate with third world immigrants
that are coming in illegally many of
them coveted positive
drug resistant tuberculosis i'm a health
care provider i can tell you it's a
disaster down there from a public health
standpoint and
they are just want to change the
electorate and put these people on a
path to citizenship enfranchise them
with a vote and have a permanent
majority
on every phase we can see every aspect
that democrats are trying to change
america from what we know what we love
and what we have enjoyed for 244 years
right
it's despicable his approval rating is
taking a big hit if you look back in
july 55
of the folks approved biden in september
44
disapproval in july it was 43 in
september it was 53 percent this is
going to be a big hit and what is this
going to look like midterms or in three
years
well we're looking at probably uh
you know we'll have two million come
across this year by the end of this year
at the end of biden's administration
it's four years he'll have eight eight
million eight million illegals will have
crossed he has no intention the
democrats that he has surrounded himself
with have absolutely no intention of of
securing this border and uh so what we
have here is a constitutional crisis and
i'll tell you our our governor greg
abbott and the great state of texas has
it within their power constitutionally
the u.s constitution article 4 section 4
of our constitution says the federal
government will guarantee each state a
republican form of government and also
protect us from invasion
and with they are absolutely not obeying
the law they are putting many many
people in danger on every aspect
terrorism criminal activity
drugs
public health you name it it's happening
and the governor needs to continue what
he's doing and that is stepping up with
our department of public safety with
texas national guard
and start securing that border ourselves
and i know i'm very proud to see them
happening and i see that happening and i
want to see it happen a lot more because
that's the only thing that's going to
save this great republican environment
it's got to be quicker it's got to be
quicker it's taken way too long by the
way as lindsey graham tweeted out the
coyotes and cartels will appreciate the
body administration removing border
patrol agents on horseback because
they're quite effective that's another
thing they're doing without even
understanding the terrain and what they
were doing they just banned it and
condemned it and that's what they want
to investigate i got to ask you too how
does all this lead to impeachment
you're one of people signing off saying
the president should be impeached
where's this going
well
with with us in the minority and with
pelosi in charge in the house
uh it's probably not going anywhere we
have to have some democrats to uh
successfully impeach
the president or anybody that he has or
any of his subordinates but many of them
need to be removed i am on
my good friend bob gibbs from ohio he's
got articles of impeachment
against president biden he's the
absolute most incompetent
uh commander in chief that we've ever
seen i think i know in my lifetime and
i'm an army and air force veteran myself
and the the things that he's done on the
border stopping the great policies that
president trump came up with and we
talked about that earlier letting
thousands of coveted positive individual
migrants come across illegally into our
country uh stopping unilaterally
stopping the federal uh uh mandate for
evictions uh against the warning of the
of the supreme court and then the
afghanistan
debacle
uh having left americans there
left 85 to 90 billion dollars worth of
assets there and not having a plan to
get american citizens out are our allies
got it all right congressman brian babin
from the great state of texas
congressman thank you very much for
joining he's a veteran his son navy seal
who wrote the book with jacob wildick
has been on our show before life